[Musique]
le département et la région célébré ce
dimanche 9 juillet la fête de l'ïul
fitre qui marque la fin du mois sacré de
Ramadan à la villa du département les
deux collectivités ont souhaité partager
ce moment chaleureux qui rassemble des
personnes de toute confession confondu
au fond le
monde vit plutôt des guerres la guerre
des différences la guerre des religions
ousutreallouvrir lesut pour dire ma
religion est une religion que je veux
être un élément rassembleur et pas un
élémentre temps fort de cette journée la
remise de l'insigne de Chevalier de la
Légion d'honneur à
idrissag président du groupe
interreligieux de la Réunion par
monseigabord
c'est un immense honneur de recevoir
cette distinction de la République c'est
une grande fierté pour moi pour ma
famille et mes proches tout au long de
cette journée festive divers concours
animation et exposition ont été
organisés tels que le concours Top
cuistau où plusieurs candidates
s'affronte pour préparer un menu
indien ce jeu top il a sa place dans la
fte de
par nous célébr et et bien c'est une
fête c'est une fête religieuse et le
jour de la justement les musulmans non
pas le droit de jeûner c'est le jour où
l'on mange le hé c'est pour embellir
pour devenir un peu plus belle se faire
plaisir et aussi ça protège du mauvais
œil ça porte chance ça porte bonheur et
on se sent complète on se sent épanouie
comblé de la tête au pied une fête de
Laï sous le signe du partage et de la
paixésente Moré de
[Musique]
Ramadan